how's everybody doing today good awesome
is Eric said my name is Andy night I
work at max point
hey max point I'm going to be here
telling you today that testing and
python is fun so a quick look at our
agenda this is very much going to be a
more of like a survey type talk I'm
going to tell about about me why I'm up
here talking we're going to cover
generic testing best practices I'm not
sure what the skill level in the room is
maybe some are experts maybe some are
novices we're going to create that nice
base of understanding so then what we're
going to do is we're going to look at a
series of Python test frameworks we're
going to go either until I run out of
slides or run out of time and any time
remaining will be open discussion and
questions this will be a non interactive
lecture in the sense that I don't expect
you to be on your computer typing along
this is meant to be an overview and a
survey if you want the slides afterwards
please let me know hopefully though I'll
try to make it fun and interesting and
exciting because some people might think
this is mundane but I love this stuff so
a little bit about me
I really don't belong at this conference
I am NOT a data scientist I'm not even a
Python guru what I am is I'm a software
engineer with a specialty in QA and test
automation I've worked at IBM I've
worked at NetApp right now I'm working
at max point max point represent and my
career path has been very much focused
on testing and test automation and so
I'm here to share my expertise with
y'all I'm very excited to be here
so just for humor at this conference
when somebody says pandas most people
are probably thinking of that that nifty
number Python package I'm thinking about
these little furry black-and-whites so
so first question for the group here how
many of you write perfect code raise
your hand
oh man we got some Q Buress going on
question one a how many of the rest of
you who didn't raise your hand think
that the people who raised their hands
right first for perfect code telling
right you know we live in a fallen world
nobody writes perfect code I don't write
perfect code that's why I test it right
I believe people write in perfect code I
want to try to mitigate that risk and
find the problems as much as possible
and we all know it deep down so we know
we don't write perfect code we know we
should be testing our code next question
is how many of you actually automate
your tests mixbag I'm seeing about
probably 40 percent 30 40 % to those who
raised your hand
awesome this is going to be an easy talk
for you for everybody else
buckle in because here we go let's talk
about some foundations of software
testing there's a distinction between
testing and debugging when I talk about
testing I'm talking about a very formal
process here testing is the process of
validating product features and of
identifying any product defects a lot of
times you hear about having test teams
or QA teams you hear about writing test
cases these step 1 through 10 procedures
hitting all these different variation
cases right
they're supposed to be results pass or
fail you're supposed to be able to cover
your code with what those results may be
to make sure you're actually hitting all
your execution paths that's what we mean
when we talk about testing it's
different than debugging debugging is
the manual process of stepping through
software code to find one-off
programming errors right a lot of people
think that when they're they're just
like banging outs on some awesome pandas
library something I don't even know what
what language whatever and all of a
sudden they they run it through the
interpreter and it crashes and they're
like ok I got to figure out what's going
on here so then they they write some
print statements or they change some
variables or they you know muck with the
code a little bit and they keep running
until finally it works ah yes that's
right
that would be debugging
is not necessarily what we will consider
testing right debugging is more of just
fiddling around hacky kind of thing
testing is a formal process and there's
many types of testing this is the story
of my life on display right
I'm not going to drill too much into the
definitions of all these things but
there are whole careers in this stuff
some of the big things to point out the
difference between manual and automated
testing manual testing is you sitting at
your computer actually interacting with
the product the software product to make
sure you're passing your test cases
automated would be I'm going to write a
program or a test script to do the
things automatically for me I'm just
going to push a button it's going to go
or I'm going to set up a system that's
going to run it automatically for me
another big difference in testing would
be exploratory versus planned right am i
going to have an explicit test scenario
steps one through ten that i'm going to
run through and i'm going to write a
check mark next to each step that i pass
or is it a situation where i'm going to
dedicate a block of time with this
product and just hit it with all the bad
nonsense i can think of and just kind of
meander through and use my expertise as
an engineer and as a product user to try
to find problems in it our talk is
largely going to focus on automated
testing plan testing and functional
testing functional meaning I want to run
some steps and verify a pass/fail result
to make sure that the thing works
because that's what we want with testing
want to make sure that thing works and
we're going to look at different Python
frameworks for that so you're thinking
okay awesome right I know I got to test
my code I know I've got to be you know
formal about it so don't miss any of my
cases I can communicate with people in
all but why would I bother to automate
my tests right you're telling me I have
to write more code for the code I just
wrote seems like this is going to be a
very large investment of my time what if
what if there's bugs in my automated
test cases
not only bugs in my code now right so
why would I spend the time to do this
number of good reasons primarily you
need to test the code anyway you need to
have those test cases to make sure it
works why not take the extra step to
automate it because automated tests can
be rerun easily and quickly right let's
say you've got a manual test case that
takes I don't know like 15 minutes to
run let's say you need to run this test
case through about you know 10 20 times
in a release right you can either spend
15 minutes each time you need to run it
or you can spend a little extra time
initially to automate it and then every
time after that it's just a push of a
button you save your time they can be
scheduled to run whenever you want
especially with integration or on
continuous integration environments you
hook it up to Jenkins or something
they can also be defensive right they
make sure that you don't break the
existing code when you add to it right
if you've got a very large project right
let's say thousands or millions of lines
of code whatever and you're adding a new
feature to that how do you know that
your new piece isn't going to magically
break something else somewhere in the
system well of course you know because
your code is perfect mmm no you don't
know right I've seen spectacular
failures in the most weird of ways it's
my job
having that automated test suite behind
you is is protection right because if
you add the new code and you hit the
button all of a sudden you've run 987
test cases against the old stuff and
you've verified I know I have full
coverage here and I know now every
single one of those 987 is passing even
after I add my new feature you get that
nice warm fuzzy feeling or the opposite
you put your code change into your
feature branch and Aldo's 987 test cases
23 have now failed oops
good thing you haven't merged that into
your main branches so that your changes
that broke the old stuff or isolate
so you can figure out now oh hey what
did I break good test cases should tell
you that right away um some other nice
things about automated test cases they
don't make mistakes when they run
they're going to run the same way each
time ever been under pressure you've run
this test case ten times before but the
11th time you forget that one step who
knows what you missed human error
oops automated frameworks can also print
pretty results your manager comes
knocking on your door hey how'd that how
that said two test cases go a little bit
no here's the nice report you see all
these check marks were good they can
show code coverage like I mentioned
before right you can there are tools
that let you see oh hey
I've hit this module or I've hit these
functions in this module these functions
in this module but none of my tests ran
functions in this module guess where you
should be writing your next tests
awesome and also just overall they
formalize your test approach right
they're making sure you're dotting your
i's and crossing your T's so how do we
write good tests we're all about in yeah
I want to write tests but how do i how
do I write good tests because there's
big difference between good tests and
bad tests um couple pointers we're not
going to drill we're not going to
belabor these details too much but just
some things to think about know the type
and scope of your tests right are you
looking to make very simple unit tests
are you looking to for something that's
going to trace through multiple steps in
your system are you looking to test you
know your module that you've written or
are you looking to test maybe somebody
else's modules that they've written that
you need to make sure they integrate
well and from their choosing the
appropriate test framework and tools
typically a single test should focus on
a single thing right if you have one
test case that's very very long and it's
checking a hundred different things and
that test case fails which of those
hundred things failed I don't know maybe
we should split that up so that your
tests are more focused so when something
does fail you know right away
boom it was feature a that just exploded
but B C and D are good also just based
on my experience writing lots and lots
of test cases you want to have the
simplest minimal setup inputs and
configuration necessary to run your
tests the more input parameters you have
the more complicated and confusing it
becomes especially if you have to share
it with somebody or share it with
another team you want to keep things
simple and focused when you do your
testing um when I write automated tests
I also like to write out my step-by-step
procedures before I do any programming
at all um one of the the recommendations
I've given folks is okay you know yeah I
know I get it
you you're you're hot and ready you want
to put your fingers on the keyboard and
start banging out some some PI code way
to go what I recommend for that is when
you make your test case function write
comment lines saying okay step one I'm
going to do this step two I'm going to
do this and then putting your code in
each after each one those lines to make
sure ah yes this is my test procedure um
another big one
separating common logic for test code
into shared test libraries right we all
know the copy/paste nightmare right
unfortunately test automation is a
sphere where a lot of people have all
these good best practices for developing
their product code and then what comes
to write and test automation they throw
it all away I don't know why because you
want to make sure your tests are
reliable especially if you're doing
something or more of a continuous
integration continuous test type of
environment so good practices for
regular code is good practices for test
code so abstract those libraries those
classes those functions make it
shareable functional tests also should
be deterministic right there should not
be these random things that expect you
don't expect to happen right if every
time I want to run a test I want to make
sure I'm getting the same expected
results and also leave no trace on your
systems this is like a Boy Scout
principle you're at the campsite right
yeah got it clean
all the 10 whatever the back same thing
for testing if you mucked up data on
your system clean it up if you had to
set up some extra processes close them
down you know Leave No Trace because
it's very easy to overlook those things
the next thing you know your system
crashes because it ran out of resources
of memory or CPU or something so quick
overview good testing practices so now
that we've got that under our belt let's
talk about some Python test frameworks
because that's why we're here this isn't
just the testing conference this is the
Python conference right Python has tons
of good testing frameworks I'm going to
cover about 5 of them there's more I
could cover I only have so much time you
only have so much attention so the first
one I'm going to cover is probably the
most basic one a unit test has everyone
heard of unit tests before has a raise
your hand if you've actually used unit
test awesome
awesome that's the majority so we're
very familiar with unit tests it's
standard Python unit test framework how
it works is it provides this test case
super class and in that class you can
override setup and teardown methods for
your site up and cleanup you have test
methods in that class test underscore
thingy thingy thingy right put your test
code in there you have assertion methods
as well a search or assert false we'll
look those in a moment any of the
methods in that class prefixed with test
underscore are going to be identified as
test methods and run as such so we
obviously in this room have a lot of
experience with unit tests it's good for
basic unit testing it's there it's easy
it's simple no frills no thrills um
however it does have some disadvantages
every test case needs to be part of this
test case needs to be a test case
subclass right so you are forced into
class inheritance for all y'all
object-oriented programmers out there
that might make you flinch a little bit
like ooh
I'm trapped yes yes you are also it
doesn't really support parameterize test
cases so everything would have to be
hard-coded in those scripts word to the
wise if you're using Python 2 it is
recommended to use the unit test 2
library instead of just the unit test
library to get python 3s advancements as
backports um and for those who are
interested you can also add on XML
report generation for your tests to
integrate into systems like Jenkins for
example the you know display your pretty
results using this unit test XML
reporting module which is separate but
you can import it so how should my
project directory look when I'm using
unit tests so at the top we'd have our
root project directory most of us are
going to put all of our Python code in
like a folder directory or something um
under there we're going to have our
product code meaning the thing that
we're actually trying to write probably
either in just op py files or in sub
directories for packages under there the
best place to put your unit tests make a
new package called tests put in an it py
file in there so it identifies it as a
package and then put files named
test-score whatever your feature product
name is and then in those files that's
where you would put your unit test
subclasses I also like to include a
readme that's what that's there for so
looking at a code example it may be a
little hard to see from up here given
the the lighting and all but um this is
just your basic unit test subclass where
we've got as you can see class
calculator test and I'm inheriting from
unit test test case which I imported up
here I have a basic set up method which
is creating a calculator class and
saving it as an attribute of my class
and then I have to test methods down
here I have test ad and test subtracts
in here you can see it's using that
stuff that I set up and it's also
calling the unit test methods assert
equals method to make sure that when I
add two different numbers that the
answer I get for the value is what I
expect to be five same thing down here
except now I'm subtracting I'm calling a
different method and I'm saying hey when
I subtract them make sure that the
answer is one so obviously number one is
three and number two is two and there
you have it very simple Python unit test
test case any questions so far
silence is gold now if you want to do
that XML report generation that I
mentioned you can easily add a main and
start using this XML Runner XML test
runner output it to a directory that'll
just enable it in your Python script
when you run that as an executable not
only will it run the tests it will print
out your XML report it's optional though
now running these tests from the command
line very simple change directory into
your project root directory and then you
can run unit tests using the Python
command run it using the unit test
module that's what this Python - M unit
test option is for and then you give the
package path to the test case so
remember we had a package called tests
and the modules name was test calc that
had that class we saw that were run all
the unit tests that it can discover you
can also choose to run test case classes
by name so in the next example we have
the same command except now instead of
referring to the module I'm also
including the test
last name so if you can have multiple
test classes in one py file but I can
choose which ones I want to run you can
also choose to discover tests from
multiple files using the discover option
for the command so let's say I have
multiple test files I just want to run
them all in one blow
boom that's how you can do it then also
referring back to that XML example I had
you can choose to run your unit tests as
they were any other Python script you
don't necessarily need to use the unit
test module to do that it'll run it as
an executable and if in the executables
mean you're showing the unit test runner
as well showed on the previous slide
it'll also run the unit tests so that is
how you run unit tests in Python but
wait there's more unit test is only one
of multiple Python test frameworks it's
the most standards the most basic is
probably the one most people know about
there's another one called doc test has
anybody heard of or use doc tests before
not as many hands up doc test is pretty
cool um let me ask this question have we
heard of doc strings raise your hand
everybody's got their hand up we all
know doc strings what are doc strings
are those awesome strings you put on
these things that you define it could be
module things or class names or like
methods or functions right and they tell
us hey this is what this thing actually
does and you can read it from your
interpreter everything's great
what if you could write test cases in
your doc strings mind-blown that's what
doc test is all about so what a doc test
is is you put basically these these test
commands into your doc strings using
this arrow arrow arrow in the doc string
text
and then you would write the command is
if you were at the Python interpreter so
if you wanted to test that add method it
could be like arrow arrow arrow add
parentheses 2 comma 3 comma over
parentheses the very next line under
that is where you will put the expected
result that you would see from the
interpreter so you put a 5 there what
the doc test will do is it will pick
that up run it as if it were running an
interpreter and make sure that what it
got is what you said it should be who
fancy how this also can do some XML
reporting you can use the same modules
that now as cool as this may be I will
caution this this is something you
should probably only do testing for like
small scripts and tools like I know a
lot of the data scientists they do a lot
of hacky kind of things with Python
that's awesome that's cool you make the
world go round
this would be applicable for that if
you're writing major software systems
probably not
I recommend doctor for you know small
small scripts small tools something
where you're testing only needs to be
very light get it out the door all that
kind of stuff so let's look at this
directory layout not really much to know
because your doc strings are going into
your source files so whatever wherever
your source files are you can stick them
in there alternatively you can you you
can you can write doc tests in separate
text files if you want to do that what I
recommend is you create a some sort of
folder in your project directory called
doc tests it doesn't have to be this but
I recommend it so you remember it and
then you can put your text files in
there and then you can shove the text
file path into the doc test command so
here's a quick example subtract method
turn a - B ok trivial I get it works for
this example though your doc tests here
are going to be in your doc string put
some some description and then those
triple arrows boom-boom-boom you can see
how I'm invoking this particular
function and I'm expecting that when I
subtract three and two I'll get a 1 and
when I subtract two and three I'll get a
negative one very lightweight very quick
to do very easy to do if we wanted to we
could add some runners to a main method
inside that same module may or may not
be what you want to do you can still run
it from the doc test command or you
could run it as an executable and if you
want to generate that XML output you can
do it like this here as well
so example invocations of this again
always change to your project root
directory and here are different ways
you can run the test commands if you've
included that main method in your module
you can just run it as a regular
executable and it will do your dog tests
if you don't have that you can run it
through the doc test module and just
push it in notice here that these are
file paths these are not package paths
different frameworks require different
things I've been burned on this before
doc test is going to expect actual file
paths something that might be tricky for
you at first also if all of your doc has
passed guess what it prints nothing that
may make you think they didn't even run
my test that's a good thing and only
prints by default if it failed something
but you can make it verbose with the
dash V option so it will print that hey
yes you Andy did run your test and it
was good same module call can be used to
run doc tests and a regular text file as
shown here and this was just an example
showing okay it's the same invocation if
you want to do the XML thing if you've
got that in your main method alright
let's look at another test framework
knows who here has heard of or used
knows before more more hands than doc
test very good knows is basically like a
better version
unit-tests right nose has some niftier
features I think their tagline is nose
makes testing easier or something that's
basically what it does it's nice it's
been around a few years what's really
nice about nose is it lets you write
tests either object oriented ly with a
test case class or simply using
functions I like functional programming
I like functions you're not tied in to
that nasty class inheritance thing
awesome
so nose again works on discovery you
want to name your your test case methods
or test functions test underscore so
that nose will know hey this is a test
case also with that test case class you
don't need to inherit from any
particular test case class like for unit
test remember you had to say oh I'm
going to inherit from unit test dot test
case it knows you don't need any
inheritance they can just inherit from
object and it'll still be identified as
a test case class why because it's named
appropriately and it could be discovered
some other nice things about nose they
handle parameters using generators or
nose parameterised so if you want to
have the same logic run different tests
for different inputs it's a little
easier than unit tests um it's also
backwards compatible nose can run unit
tests tests it can run doc test tests so
if you've already got many of those
types of tests in your in your code
repository your framework whatever your
code base you can just start using nose
and use nose to run those old ones as
well to keep it all the same some
warnings not all plugins for nose are
compatible with Python 3 and also a nose
is not really actively supported anymore
so my recommendation would be use nose
more for legacy projects or to keep code
bases that are using notes going
directory layouts pretty pretty standard
the biggest difference between this and
the one for unit tests is that the test
should not be in a package hierarchy
they can just be flat or flat directory
system knows does not need to identify
modules or it does not need to identify
modules as in some sort of package
hierarchy which is nice you don't need
that pesky init file you can have it if
you want but it's not necessary there's
also this knows CFG file you can add
extra options in there you can either
specify them on the command line or you
can provide them here things like
generating XML reports do you want to
capture output all those sorts of things
I'm not going to drill too much into
that but um the documents the
documentation online for knows is pretty
comprehensive if we look at an example
nose test you'll see this is going to be
a little bit simpler than the unit test
example here we don't need a class we
just have functions right I import some
nose stuff at the top if I'm looking at
s tad function I'm just saying hey you
know add these two numbers and I'm using
pythons basic assert statement to make
sure it's good what's nice about the
assert statement you don't need a clunky
library and it will print out this line
to make sure the okay yes when I fail I
know exactly where I failed uhm knows
also provides some nice built-in support
for verifying exceptions right what if
you're writing a function and it hits an
exceptional case not for good reasons
but for bad reasons and you want to make
sure that it actually throws the
exception and the exception that you
expect and maybe the exception that has
certain data in it the raises attribute
and nose will let you catch those
exceptions instead of having to
implement a try-catch block inside of
your method so we look at some more nose
examples here this is an example of a
generator in nose this allows me to
basically provide almost like a stream
of data
into one specific function to run
multiple tests so here I have a function
called test maximum I want to test that
when I run a maximum function that I'm
actually getting the maximum value so in
my test generator function I'm saying
for basic for loop for this tuple inside
this list of tuples yield the result
Python keyword of some other function
with some inputs that other function is
up here assert that the maximum is the
number that I expect it to be so this
way I have separated these out and
basically I get three different test
cases for the price of only two
functions so I don't need to hard-code
test maximum one test maximum two tests
maximum three that whole copy/paste
nightmare yes how do I launch those
tests even easier than unit tests change
directory to your project and if you
just want to run everything from that
directory down to be discovered as a
test just use the nose tests command
running all tests in a module you can
specify that path running all tests are
running a specific test function you can
drill down to that specific function
path you can specify class names and
nose comes with a lot of options that
you can build in as well now you might
be wondering okay so nose is great I've
used nose before but you just told me
it's not really being actively
maintained it's got a little bit of
support lingering around but the future
does not look bright is there something
better out there there is high test gay
Pi test is a mature fully featured
Python testing tool it's actively
supported both Python two and three is
very very similar to notes basically I
think Python or PI test is like knows
better for the present day same thing
you can write tests as functions or
class methods and the way PI test does
set up clean up and all they
actually have a fixture framework for
that where you're basically passing
around these these subroutines to try to
set things up or tear them down or set
up directories bunch of built-in stuff
there a test can also be easily
parameterised much more easily than a
nose assert statements are a little bit
better as well because you can use the
basic Python assert statement but PI
tests include some advanced
introspection to make sure that
everything is kosher and good and print
out extra stuff for you there's also a
plugin plugin framework where you can
extend PI test directory layout it's
basically the same as knows you can also
have instead of course you're not going
to have a nose CFG file you'd have this
ini file that can specify certain things
um one thing I will warn make sure your
Python path is set with nose if you
don't have it set to whatever
directories are what properly you're
going to find PI test is not going to
pick up your tests I've I've had some
people ask me questions about that
they've been very unhappy it wasn't
documented so I'm going to make sure I
pass the information on to you looking
at a PI test example we can see
similarities with what we saw a nose
here we've got these test functions uh
that test add function is almost
identical right PI tests can run those
tests backwards compatibility cool stuff
uh catching exceptions is a little bit
different there's this PI test dot
raises that you use with high test
raises and the type of the exception you
want to catch attempt this and this will
evaluate to make sure hey did you
actually catch this exception or not
this is a little bit more flexible I
think there's some more options in here
where you can specify other things as
well and then parameterizing doesn't
need that generator thing what you can
do is you can basically spill out okay I
have a function let's say test maximum
it's going to take in two things and an
expected value and I can just basically
lists in tuples
hey when number one and number two are
maximized or when you take the maximum
of those two you should get number one
let's reverse the order let's use the
same number
boom boom you can get multiple test
variations very easily different
combinations of input same test logic
here
no copy/paste nonsense in order to
launch your PI tests again command line
stuff change directory to your your
project make sure you set the PI path
core Python path correctly to run all
tests to be discovered in that directory
use the PI dot test command listing all
tests with their results as are run out
of verbose option you can specify the
path to specific tests very standard and
you can also specify modules at all I
should mention this right now before I
forget I should have mentioned it sooner
oh noes and PI tests are available for
download through pip you basically just
say pip install those pip install I test
fill install into whatever either
globally in your environment or virtual
environment and these commands this the
nose tests commander the PI test command
they're part of that installation when
it installs it'll install these as
command-line executables for you granted
your paths are all kosher so that's why
those don't run Python something they
actually run a command line which is
Python under the covers some more
examples of high test execution you can
generate that XML report you can also do
code coverage very easily with an extra
module you can install make sure you get
a report that says ok I've hit these
lines and these paths and these modules
very useful to them and you can also
print some help options finally the last
framework I'm going to talk about today
is avocado has anybody heard of avocado
some some avocado was developed by Red
Hat it's it's actually put that I
actually pretty slick as far as test
frameworks go
you can run tests written in any
language not just Python the folk
there seems to be Python Bosch and C
programs when you write in Python though
you want your test to be subclasses of
avocado test so again we're kind of back
in that unit test clunkiness
everything's going to be an avocado test
not just a unit test in fact I think
avocado tests inherits from unit test
again standard stuff each method should
be named test underscore whatever their
standard setup and cleanup methods the
outline and that structure is very
similar to unit tests but there's
there's a lot more that avocado offers
you it has some special attributes of
one of which is white board a white
board is going to be a string that's
going to save it's going to be saved
automatically with test results so let's
say you're in your test and you're
you're doing all sorts awesome data
pandas who knows whatever stuff and your
test just blows up in the middle and it
just dies right and there was data in
there that you would really like to know
for debugging purposes if you save it to
white board that's going to be splat it
out once through test is over
better or worse very useful or you can
use it for other things as well also
there's a parameters attribute that
allow it's a way for you to communicate
from the outside taking some test
parameters that you want to pass in and
then making them accessible to any test
there's also a log which is convenient
for logger you can just print lines as
you go to say hey I'm tracing this and
tracing this and tracing this not all
test frameworks have something like that
but it's very useful rather than setting
up your own logs there's other advanced
features almost too many to name
there's parameter multiplexing where you
can set apart different parameter
scenarios I guess King it can go pretty
deep couple levels test discovery you
know finding tests without having to
explicitly name paths result formatting
options job replay if something fails
the first time can I run it again right
away or can I take an instance that was
already run and run under the same
conditions a remote test run GDB all
that good stuff one warning
it's Linux only they you can download
the github project try to compile in
Windows I've never done that don't know
if it's going to work but it is a Linux
II kind of thing so standard directory
layout running out of time okay I'm out
of time
sure sure sure so you can look up online
for avocado code all that good stuff
running it in summary real quick what
should you use long story short you spy
test but each one does have their own
unique benefits to consider as well
thank you